what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time i'm here with
paulina ivalova marinova pompliano and
she's wearing uh this is a carol
baskin-esque
type of outfit to ask me why i was
wearing it i didn't say
make your best educated guess as to why
i'm wearing it i'm wearing this
today in honor of carol baskin who got
eliminated
last night on dancing with the stars
very upset
very wrong judgment by the people
i'm surprised that she was on dancing
with the stars she did a lion king
samba it wasn't great but it's carol
baskin
guys who allegedly killed her husband
okay okay let's not get into details
well i'm just saying we're
we're celebritizing somebody who killed
somebody potentially
allegedly allegedly allegedly okay
ready we're the responsible news here no
problem
don't forget that black flight's now a
sponsor of what's going on okay go on
sorry does it make you feel like a cat
okay
uh black friday's not sponsored by lunch
or uh sorry lunch money is now sponsored
by block five
one day block five may be sponsored by
lunch money but right now lunch money
sponsored by block five
uh you can buy and sell crypto on crypto
exchange you can earn up to eight point
six percent apy in an interest bearing
account go check it out blockfy.com
no brainer go get money get paid at
blockfi what's up okay so
home prices rose 4.8
in july strong demand from home buyers
in july coupled with rock bottom
mortgage interest rates caused home
prices to accelerate
in major markets across the nation do
you think this is sustained like do you
think this will
continue throughout the year well it's
like any
asset right so of course you can create
a bubble but if you have cheap capital
flooding the market which you do you
have a low interest rate environment
uh and people are being transient in the
sense of
people are moving out of new york
they're moving out of san francisco
they're moving to other places right
there
it's almost like um there was uh the
world got shaken up a little bit people
like
where do i want to live what do i want
to do oh i don't have to be here for
work now i can like work remotely
all that kind of stuff there's a lot of
moving um but also then you're getting
uh the cheap capital so
it makes sense that it's happening how
sustainable is it
we'll see but if we keep interest rates
at uh near zero
for years i mean economists said
the u.s housing market has been caught
up in a perfect storm during the covert
pandemic the substantial swing in demand
is driven by a need for indoor and
outdoor space met by record low mortgage
rates and a wave of millennials who are
on the verge of buying all competing for
fewer and fewer homes on the market
dang those millennials makes sense
okay do you like it do i like that
they're rising
yeah i mean good for the people who own
the houses
yeah well but it also means if you own a
house your property value's going down
that's what i'm saying good for the
people who own property yeah
or the people selling too because they
get the cash all right what's next okay
so on the flip side new york
bankruptcies reportedly surged 40
during the pandemic bloomberg reported
that 610 businesses filed for bankruptcy
in the southern eastern districts of new
york from march to september
another flurry of bankruptcies and
permanent closures are expected as cold
weather
arrives i don't think that that's
nearly as high as i would have thought
really six
610 businesses you know hundreds of
thousands if not millions
yes but some of those businesses are
parent companies that own a bunch of
smaller ones
so for example century 21 is the parent
company of chuck e cheese
and neiman marcus yeah so the individual
companies are filing bankruptcy but
that's even more of a case like if
century 21
gets into a bad situation then that
would be three bankruptcies century 21
chuck e cheese i'm saying
yeah i don't think they're counting all
the trickle-down effects yeah well
they're probably counting each legal
entity that files for bankers because
they're they're counting the bankruptcy
filings
yeah the hard part is just like it's
definitely going to get worse
way worse um because yelp is showing
that 4 000 new york city businesses have
permanently closed central markets and
that's because
owners of small businesses are less
likely to file for bankruptcy instead
many are simply leaving the keys in the
door what does that mean
basically it's just like hey it's over i
don't have a bunch of
better like you know i don't owe a bunch
of debt it's kind of like
just we ran to the end of the business
we're going to shut down the business i
don't know
but bankruptcy specific protection
meaning that like
you got in a situation where now you
can't pay people back or you owe people
money
some small businesses are like i'm just
gonna cut my losses it's over i'm gonna
yeah it's over i don't owe anybody any
money like i'm just gonna
go do something else now right so so the
bankruptcies
i guess like yeah you would you would
expect obviously bankruptcies to be much
less
lower than the number of companies that
are closing but still to have
less than a thousand bankruptcies uh
given the economic shock we just
you know kind of sustained is very
surprising don't you think some of them
are still operating on some of the ppp
loans and money and for sure but
still even with that pvp money like
let's say that 20 i think it's 20 of
businesses are still shut is the
national average
and so that ppp money how much did they
give you
two months three months for even if they
gave you five months
yeah of of kind of operating revenue
you're not and you're still shut meaning
you have zero revenue like it's over
right it's been more than five months
since this happened so i don't know it's
just uh it's obviously a very bad
situation
okay elon musk says he will likely take
starlink satellite internet service
public
in several years do you know what
starlink is
isn't that his one of his many many
companies that does satellites
i don't know if it's a separate legal
entity but it's part of spacex
and the whole idea is he's basically
created a
network or a star link of satellites
yeah constellation uh i actually think
that's the word they use um
that is uh outside of earth right it's
in space and it
is supposed to be able to provide uh
internet
to the public and so i can't remember if
they are doing this
as completely free internet or just
low-cost
internet but the idea is if you can take
all these satellites and basically cover
the world
in internet that's great for humanity
it's a great business to be in
um and it sounds like he's got ambitions
to spin it out
and take it public uh but he needs a
couple of years to kind of
get it to the point where he thinks
that'll make sense yeah he said we will
probably ipo
starlink but only several years in the
future when revenue growth is smooth and
predictable
public market does not like erratic cash
flow
haha i'm a huge fan of small retail
investors we will make sure
they get top priority you can hold me to
it
elon musk understands the internet
better than most all right what's next
spotify ceo you know how he just
uh made this thing he made a pledge that
he was gonna
back european moonshot companies he made
his one of his first investments to back
a tesla
rival after pledging to invest over 1
billion in european moonshots
it's the company is a swedish battery
company called north
volt i've heard of that before i don't
know why um it's aiming to develop the
world's greenest lithium-ion
ion battery and it has caught the eye of
some
of europe's biggest car companies yeah i
mean look
when you pledge money to a specific
region like
europe you're going to be beholden to
whatever the best companies in europe
are right and so
then when you overlay moon shots on top
of it uh
that means you're not going to be doing
it you literally get lithium ion
and space companies yeah it's just
there's only so many companies to choose
from and so you got to write big checks
to them
uh but this one actually like is pretty
interesting in that we know
lithium-ion technology and batteries
will be incredibly valuable in the
future the question's always just been
like
who's going to be first to get there uh
and who's going to be the one who can do
it
with any sort of success and it's
based in sweden so he's probably very
familiar with it because spotify is also
based in sweden
yep um and x said i get really
frustrated when i see european
entrepreneurs giving up on their amazing
vision selling early on to non-european
companies
or when some of the most promising tech
talent in europe leaves because they
don't feel
valued here we need more super companies
that raise the bar and can act as
inspiration
love it all right so apple
versus epic games so a judge
is not very kind to epic or was not very
kind
a federal judge presiding over a
high-stakes anti-trust lawsuit between
apple and epic games
maker of the popular video game fortnite
repeatedly slammed epic on monday on its
legal
theories and tactics in the company's
case against the ios app store do you
want to remind us what this was all
about
basically apple has a lockdown ecosystem
on the app store
and google has an open one so uh what
you need to do in order to use
apple's app store is you have to submit
an application
for something they review it they
approve it and there's certain
guidelines you have to abide by
one of those guidelines is that you have
to give apple
30 of any purchase that's done inside of
your app
uh absurd uh and then um like literally
highway robbery
uh and then on top of that you've got to
uh
uh you're not allowed to create another
app store inside of your app
right so you can't create like a
marketplace inside of a marketplace and
so
uh epic games which is the owner of
fortnite or producer fortnite
they basically have been trying to push
apple saying you don't treat everyone
the same
we want special treatment uh and apple
was like no no no no no
and they blocked it from the app store
well only after
fortnite and epic said okay fine we're
gonna do it anyways and they pushed the
code
and uh they were ready though it was it
was bait
because they knew that apple was gonna
take them by the app store and the
second apple took them out of the app
store
they released this ridiculously awesome
uh marketing campaign that basically was
just saying apple is a monopoly apple's
become the man
and we're fighting back against the man
like free fortnight
and uh what's interesting is apple like
is going to court over this so epic
filed lawsuits and apple kind of
countered
uh with an argument but they're gonna go
to court at the same time google has
taken the exact opposite approach
google's like cool what do you guys want
to do you guys want to create app stores
inside of our uh
app store suite and they're like
building that i saw a report on that so
it ultimately is going to come down to
there's a lot of companies that do not
agree on
having to pay the 30 to apple
uh and they point to uh one there's
companies that get special treatment
netflix and others
uh two some people actually get to use
their own payment processors inside
their app rather than
uh have to use apples so i think it's
like amazon primes video app does that
etc
and then three is there's no competition
so what
fortnite did was it said hey if you want
to use apple's payment technology
you have to pay let's say 10 right
but if you pay us directly and don't
pay through apple's technology we'll
give it to you for eight dollars
and the difference is that fortnite
was going to give you a 20 discount but
that was really the 30 percent they used
to pay for apple
right so now they were saying hey we're
gonna make a little bit more rather than
make seven dollars gonna make eight
dollars
and we're gonna save you the consumer
more money we're gonna cut out apple
obviously apple didn't like this and
that's kind of kicked all of this off
but i do think that we are going to see
uh sometime in the near future
uh this gets struck down where apple
cannot hold the line uh
on charging 30 mainly because uh i think
that the lack of competition
in the app store for pricing is gonna
become a really really big problem well
the judge isn't a big fan of epic let me
tell you that
well they don't like the fact that hey
you knew you had a contract and you
actively violated the contract
right uh epic's point is yes
but that contract has issues but
whatever so we'll see how it plays out
all right are you ready yeah so
i'm happy about this okay you can just
hit accept all cookies but i don't do i
want to accept the cookies
yes researchers have
researchers have detected a group of
lakes hidden
under mars's surface like saltwater
lakes guys
so um we're going to mars
i don't know if i'm going to be alive
for it but we're going to mars
so two years ago planetary scientists
reported the discovery of a large
saltwater lake under the ice at mars
south pole a finding that was met with
excitement and skepticism
now researchers have confirmed the
presence of that lake
and found three more i wonder why it's
like under the surface
well i guess that's where water is
typically that i mean that's one option
but also
there's there's just like a lot of
atmosphere things right that go on
uh and also like we haven't even
necessarily discovered every place on
planet earth remember that
right like there's still parts of planet
earth that we have not been to
no wa there's definitely parts of the
ocean we've never been into oh you mean
like
the depths of the okay so hold on that's
one place there's absolutely places
where
uh we find like you ever seen in like
the amazon for example we come up and
like oh my god look at these people
they've never had human contact with
like an outside
uh group of people right and they're
literally still in like loincloths and
have like spheres i don't think that's
the amazon but yeah
i think that there's a couple of places
on earth right but like so yes there are
humans but like we
as the you know general society don't
know about there's also plenty of places
where people are probably
i think we should go there but they've
just never gone and so it's like have we
been to every part of antarctica no
my point being if on earth after having
inhibited it for so long
we still haven't gone to every single
place inhabited
inhibited inhabited definitely not
inhibited okay all right inhabited
that sounds like lived here uh then
there's no way that we've done that for
mars
so if we wanna see everything that's on
mars we would have to
go and explore it but it's gonna take
forever so it's like we're gonna find
tons of stuff that we don't know about
yet
including water and maybe life like what
happens if we find aliens on mars y'all
would be
shook but okay why do you believe we
won't
because like we've sent rovers there i
think the aliens would have found us if
like
there was a rover rovering around but
before before
humans as we know it civilization walked
across the bering strait for those of
you who know what geography is the
bearing straight you know where that is
yeah where what the bering strait do you
know where that is
on earth that's what connected
russia to north america and when they
walked across the bering strait
if we had sent a rover we weren't on
this planet we'd send a rover to north
america before that happened
we'd be like oh there's no life there
facts yeah but
the thing is that we have telescopes we
can see like
also what do you think we see why we
sent her over there to go explore
because the telescopes can't see
everything
oh did you know that most telescopes
can't even see the flag on the moon
is it there oh my god i will
okay when i when we first moved here and
i didn't speak any english i remember in
fourth grade we took
geology i had a geology class and we um
watched what was that show called the
magic school bus i
loved that they would like go inside the
earth
and you see the layers and even though i
didn't speak english i was like i know
what that is
um and then i had another point
all right what's next do we think life
is on mars
are you in the no camp right now i'm in
the no camp
you need some science to convince
yourself yes but i'm
very optimistic about the salt water
links
okay sounds good okay give me your dad
joke
all right when my wife told me to stop
impersonating a flamingo
i had to put my foot down
oh no you oh
it wasn't funny i know the people
laughed they got my wasn't funny
she thought she almost thought that she
had me god i was like of all the jokes
this is the one you laugh at but yeah
the one that's not funny exactly very
good all right guys that's it for lunch
monday today
have a great tuesday have a blessed
tuesday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends